the economic downturn has obviously made
people a lot more aware of just making
blanket statements we're going to do all
good things you become more frugal when
you realize you don't have resources for
everything and I think in many ways it's
been helpful for the climate debate and
helpful for many other debates that
we've had this downturn because we had a
tendency to just promise the world but
not actually living up to it and now we
can start having a conversation of
saying all right instead of making all
these grand promises what actually works
and what works effectively that's what
we've tried to answer with the
Copenhagen consensus where we asked some
of the world's top economists across the
board where can you invest the most
frugally where can you invest the most
effectively if the outcome of the
economic downturn is that we end up
spending our money much much better I
think it could all in all turn out to
have been a big silver lining